[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce numéro
spécial été du satuc loisirs à des
rendez vous sportifs des rendez vous
culturels de quoi profiter d'un grand
nombre d'activités sans quitter le
département tout de suite le sommaire
l'été est déjà lancé l'idée de loisy la
commanderie le vélodrome tous les sites
saint quentinois ouvrent leurs portes
pour vous proposer de nombreuses
activités de ville en ville le cinéma
des poissons d'écrans géants partout
dans les îles est organisée par le
département par l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines de nombreuses
projections sont programmées et l'agenda
complet de vos sorties au programme des
châteaux des monuments et des visites
des parcours pour se balader des centres
équestres les yvelines regorge d'idées
pour se dépenser
focus sur deux sites saint quentinois où
le sport prend toute sa place pendant
l'été au vélodrome nationale les équipes
sont dans les starting blocks pour vous
faire passer des vacances sportives
les saint quentinois auront accès
gratuitement aux activités cyclistes
vous allez avoir des parcours vtt avec
des initiations du côté de lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
vous avez également toute la partie
baptême bmx session et initiation on est
en train de valider la possibilité
d'installer une petite piste de paume
trac pour des mini ride et pour les plus
petits l'été sera aussi sportif à lille
de loisirs l'accrobranche ou le beach
volley sont bien sûr proposé pour son
village estivale du 15 juillet au 14
août le site vous réservent de nouvelles
découvertes non par exemple du coccyx
bola donc le principe c'est de lancer
une balle avec en tirant sur un sur un
tissu on a dû de l'archerie tags
donc on se tire dessus avec des arcs et
des flèches avec tes bout en bout ce
donc en toute sécurité
évidemment et tous les jours on a une
dizaine ou une quinzaine d'animateurs
qui vont être là et on est en
partenariat avec tout le mouvement
sportif sportif local et départemental
après tous ces efforts l'île de loisirs
proposera un parcours fraîcheur à partir
du 22 juillet plus de raison de ne pas
tester une nouvelle activité de
nombreuses communes saint-quentinoise
organisent leur village d'été petit tour
d'horizon à la verrière les festivités
débutent le 20 juillet au parc cousteau
pour sa nouvelle édition de verifone
plus des ateliers des balades et des
jeux vous seront proposés maurepas lance
son grand village estivale pour cette
première édition le stade du bois et que
jeux gonflables géants stand de
maquillage défi santé les animations
sont présentes
jusqu'au 30 juillet à elancourt les
animations sont itinérantes et
différentes destinées aux tout petits
aux plus grands et aux familles vous
pourrez en profiter jusqu'au 17 juillet
les villages d'été ont aussi pris place
à tram jusqu'au 29 août
quatre lieux de la ville sont animés par
des ateliers des jeux et des sorties
guyancourt célèbre l'été pendant deux
mois vous pourrez participer à des
rallyes photos des ateliers de
percussions ou encore pratiquer la
fitness à montigny le bretonneux l'été
en sable se passera dans les maisons de
quartier
au programme des activités robotique
créative ou encore scientifique
le parc du château de plaisir joue sur
deux ambiances zen et sports face au
farniente sur les transats les vtt
seront présents début des festivités le
20 juillet et on termine avec villepreux
le cinéma la danse et le yoga se
partagent la vedette des animations à
vivre et à partager devant la piscine et
au v parc
pour compléter ce rapide panorama
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur les
sites internet des villes concernées
on continue sur cette ut loisirs
spéciales était de deux nouveaux rendez
vous pendant plusieurs mois la culture a
été à l'arrêt mais il en faut plus pour
stopper toutes les activités plusieurs
sites saint quentinois ont choisi de
vous faire vivre un été donc très
artistique regarder et des comédiens
professionnels fait le théâtre cet été
pour la troisième année la compagnie les
tréteaux de france revient à lille de
loisirs pour une semaine de partage des
ateliers des des saynètes des petites
pièces de théâtre et des vrais
représentation donc qu'ils sont qui sont
assurés par des comédiens professionnels
et qui là sont aussi gratuite donc
idem ces inscriptions obligatoires en
revanche sur le site mais c'est vraiment
un projet qui est super pendant dix
jours fente
le site propose aussi des afterwork
chaque jeudi au restaurant les alizés
musique et jeux sont annoncés une
exposition la découverte des métiers de
la radio complètent toute cette
programmation à la commanderie l'art se
mêle à la science jusqu'au 31 juillet
les jeunes de 6 à 17 ans découvre à
travers différence d'âge la danse et les
arts visuels
on est quatre ans mission installer ici
et l'idée c'est qu'on propose aussi au
public de traverser tous les genres
qu'on défend à la commanderie les
enfants sont vraiment en immersion et
c'est ce qui nous intéresse aussi dans
ce projet de c'est les vacances c'est
que les enfants soient en immersion
toute la journée avec l'artiste avec
l'intervenant est avec ses petits
copains d'ateliers du côté du musée de
la ville les expositions sont prolongées
et en ces temps compliqués les équipes
rivalisent d'imagination pour faire
découvrir le patrimoine saint quentinois
et également des visites à vélo qui sont
des formules qui sont très chouette
l'été et faut dire que saint quentin en
yvelines offre une quantité de sentiers
de chemin qu'on peut utiliser un vélo et
qui permettent vraiment de re découvrir
ce territoire autrement et souvent les
gens sont sont vraiment surpris de ce
dont on peut parcourir l'ensemble du
territoire du land art à la balade
connecter de nombreux autres activités
sont proposées l'été sera culturel à
saint quentin en yvelines pour faire
vivre des moments musicaux la scène
nationale quitte un temps son théâtre
avec le musée national de port royal il
propose des concerts en plein air une
invitation voyage entre les rives de la
méditerranée et l'angleterre
on écoute lionel masse et à le directeur
du théâtre
on va essayer de voyager on s'était dit
que c'était l'occasion d'aller sur des
labels ras des musiques croisés ou des
musiques plurielles comme on veut et de
voyager entre les les rites méditerranée
jusqu'à l'angleterre et puis revenir en
espagne essayé de traverser à la fois
des styles et les époques
c'est une heure de concert parce qu'il
ya une heure de concert sans entracte
parce que
mine de rien on a beau être en péril de
déconfinement c'est un déconfinement
progressive donc on est tenu à on est
astreint certaine à certaines règles
peut-être que vous ne le connaissez pas
les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine vous
donne un coup de pouce pour vos sorties
le pass malin vous permet de bénéficier
d'au moins 15% de réductions dans une
soixantaine de sites touristiques
la liste des partenaires et le pas sont
à retrouver sur le site internet sorties
retirer yvelines point fr et si vous
profitez justement de se passe pour vous
rendre à poissy le musée du jouet vous
accueille du mercredi au dimanche vous
pourrez découvrir sur réservation les
jouets à travers l histoire les sorties
au château peuvent aussi être une idée
et dans les yvelines il ya bien sûr du
choix le plus célèbre d'entre eux le
château de versailles accueille du
public depuis le 6 juin dernier
réservation et masques sont la nouvelle
norme mais la visite devient presque
privé même organisation à rambouillet
l'ancienne demeure royale a modifié son
organisation pour partager son histoire
le site propose aussi des balades et des
visites contées dans les jardins du côté
des châteaux privés laissez vous tenter
par le château de breteuil le monument
bâti à choisel continue à vous faire
vivre les contes de perrault et depuis
le 24 juin un escape game vous entraîne
en 1912 autre monument à vous accueillir
le domaine de dampierre les jardins ont
de nouveau secret à vous révéler le site
a ouvert le 30 mai dernier
l'été c'est aussi l'occasion de voir ou
de revoir des films la commanderie à
elancourt se transforme en salle de
cinéma
chaque jeudi de l'été des fines ils sont
projetés on jette un coup d'oeil
est ce que vous croyez c'est comme ça
vous allez gagner
ce juste participé aux débuts de rigoler
vous avez toujours mais tant pis on va
aller courir d'égout ballon dégagé
minutes d'arrêt
tout cela semble avoir été répété
comment l équipe claqué votre
embrouilles en fait je la laisse aller
au bout de son délire à venise
by jove à
azur et asmar l'histoire de deux enfants
devenu prince dans un conte des mille et
une nuits
[Musique]
vous dites que vous avez fabriqué une
machine à voyager dans le temps à partir
d'une delorean
il fait faire un martyr un bond de 30
ans dans le passé
[Musique]
le site aurait dû rouvrir le 4 avril
dernier mais l'épidémie de kobe de 19 en
a décidé autrement les 117 monuments de
france miniature ont dû patienter trois
mois avant d'accueillir à nouveau leur
public c'est chose faite depuis le 26
juin sujet réalisé avec mathilde et demi
et jules cachin une visite quasiment
privé pour la première matinée
d'ouverture de france miniature une
centaine de personnes est venue
découvrir les grands monuments français
c'est à part qu'on affectionne
particulièrement on adore se promener
ici et comme bien peu de monde
finalement on n'a même pas besoin
d'avoir le masque parce qu'on peut très
bien se promener tranquillement sans
rencontrer grand monde ça se passe très
très bien c'est l'un de mes parc préféré
c'est vraiment génial
il ya des petits traits partout c'est
super les enfants sont contents on peut
multiplier se balader comme on veut il
n'y a pas de problème de distanciation
on respire un peu on va dire des enfants
en fait il avait très envie de venir on
avait prévu d'y aller pour
l'anniversaire du grand qui était le 30
mars mais du coup comme c'était fermé
voilà donc dès leur ouverture on a dit
on y va
mais les garçons au pied c'est très
contente que c'était une surprise elle
la reprise s'est donc fait tout en
douceur pour l'équipe du site élan
courtois
les monuments n'avait pas vu deux
publics depuis le mois de novembre
c'était aussi une volonté d'ouvrir à
vendredi pour commencer sereinement et
doucement et dès ce week end je pense
qu'on va accueillir un petit peu plus de
monde on a quelques réservations en
ligne
et puis notre communication vient d'être
lancée également jusqu'à la veille jeudi
25 juin les salariés peaufiner les
derniers réglages sur le pont depuis la
mi mai ils ont pris soin de la demeure
du roi soleil
alors il restait pas mal de choses
notamment sur versailles là
la fin de la restauration c'est une
maquette qu'on restaure en plusieurs
fois tel tantale est grande
il ya à peu près 200 m² de maquettes sur
le parc donc on a fait en trois fois en
mars dernier l'élan de france miniature
est stoppé net par le confinement des
cds par l'état à deux semaines d'une
réouverture annuel et 15 salariés
permanents sont placés en chômage
partiel et les grilles restent closes
c'est évidemment très très impactant
pour france miniature qui accueille
chaque année deux cent mille visiteurs
et ça depuis trois ans on avait une
belle remontée de la fréquentation
depuis ces trois dernières années compte
tenu de toutes les nouveautés qu'on
avait installé quatre familiale enfin
qui répondait aux attentes de notre
public et ils sont ces trois mois de
l'ouverture et de nos ouvertures plus
exactement on a perdu près de cent mille
de nos visiteurs attendus accès
visiteurs et files d'attentes repenser
salariés supplémentaires pour veiller au
bon respect des consignes ou encore
espace fermé non accessibles france
miniature est ouvert tous les jours de
l'été un tour de l'hexagone en une seule
journée
les monuments continue de rouvrir leurs
portes pour partager leurs histoires à
rambouillet le palais du roi de rome a
repris ses visites ville d'art et
d'histoire un rendez vous organisé
chaque dimanche plusieurs thèmes sont
proposés le jardin anglais le passé de
rambouillet comme ville impériale ou au
temps des présidents des précisions
delga brillante et rouillé au micro de
mathilde et demi elle s'adresse à tous
les publics sont vraiment d'éviter tout
public ont elles sont principal vise
principalement les adultes nous avons
aussi des programmes jeune public mais
néanmoins on peut y venir en famille
avec des enfants et des adolescents
l'été c'est aussi l'occasion de réviser
tout en s'amusant et les cahiers de
vacances sont souvent une place de choix
dans les valises parmi les nombreux
carnets proposer un petit nouveau se
présente cette année c'est l'éditeur de
jeux guillon courtois asmodée qui en est
à l'origine
28 pages d'activité inspiré des
meilleurs jeux de l'entreprise avant de
se quitter je vous propose un petit top
3 celui des activités à ne surtout pas
manquer dans le département regardez
[Musique]
nous
même
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set loisirs spéciale
était vous pouvez revoir cette émission
en replay sur notre site internet où
notre application mobile
profitez bien de vos vacances tout en
restant prudent on se retrouve à la
rentrée pour toujours plus d'idées
sorties passé un très bel été sur tv 78
[Musique]